bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale on commence tout de
suite avec les titres nous parlerons
transport dans ce film avec les moves un
événement du plus grand pôle de
compétitivité de la Recherche et
Développement automobile qui s'est tenu
aujourd'hui à Versailles pour parler de
la mobilité de demain ce jeudi était
également l'occasion de découvrir les
vélos électriques une animation
organisée par une entreprise de
manilhéamo pour des salariés de Montigny
et puis le dossier de la semaine portera
sur le budget des communes comment faire
des économies des maires des environs
nous répondent nous retrouvons enfin
pour l'entretien Marianne Herard bonsoir
vous êtes membre du réseau business net
donc c'est un réseau finalement pas
comme les autres vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi dans un instant les
avant cela on passe à l'actualité
économique de la semaine
les avocats crient leur ras-le-bol ce
matin le Barreau de Versailles s'est
engagé auprès de ce mouvement de grève
nationale l'objet de leur colère
l'absence de proposition de la
Chancellerie sur la réforme du système
de la juridictionnelle il demande
notamment plus de budget pour cette aide
très utile à de nombreux justiciables
elle permet en effet à ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens de se payer un avocat dit
payant en aurait libre d'avoir tout de
même recours à un avocat rémunéré selon
un barème réaction du président de la
section des Syndicat des Avocats de
France au micro de Yolaine Torres ce
barème est extrêmement faible on
considère qu'il ne s'agit pas réellement
d'une rémunération mais bien plutôt
d'une indemnisation car en général les
dossiers sont entre guillemets
déficitaires ces dossiers nécessitant
peut-être plus de temps que les autres
plus de soins plus d'attention pour une
rémunération qui est sans aucun rapport
avec les diplômes des avocats qui
consentent à exercer au Tibet de la
directionnel le temps passé etc etc
les mauvaises se sont tenues aujourd'hui
à Versailles un événement pour la
recherche et développement automobile et
la mobilité Moveo est un pôle de
compétitivité qui fait derrière les
principaux acteurs de l'industrie
automobile comme Renault PSA Valeo mais
aussi des laboratoires des académies ou
encore de grandes écoles il compte 350
membres dont 190 PME cette journée était
l'occasion de mettre en avant les
avancées de ses membres avec un budget
de fonctionnement public et privé de 2,5
millions d'euros Moveo a contribué à
créer 200 emplois en 2013 au programme
de la journée des ateliers des
conférences des démonstrateurs avec pour
thème la mobilité de demain mais quand
on part demain le président de mouvéo
nous répond
tout ce qui est comme on dit soft
aujourd'hui c'est à dire traitement de
données et va forcément plus vite que de
la recherche qui touche par exemple la
voiture
autonome à parler du Google Car mais
Google car il n'y a pas Google qui le
fait on sait le faire ici la question
n'est pas de savoir le faire la question
c'est de le faire de manière à ce que
cette voiture
soit
à un prix abordable il y a beaucoup
d'innovations à mettre dans la capacité
à rendre les innovations accessibles à
chacun s'agit pas de faire des voitures
à un million de dollars qui
intéresseront personne ça ça peut être
des démonstrateurs il s'agit de
travailler sur la capacité qu'on aura à
rendre une voiture de plus en plus
autonome par exemple aujourd'hui on sait
qu'il y a des voitures qui se gare toute
seule ça vous le voyez dans la rue on
peut en acheter on peut en acheter une
demain elle pourra aller dans un parking
toute seule au sortir du parking tout
seul après
sont les usages la législation les
questions de sécurité
qui vont entrer en ligne de compte mais
on peut considérer que dans un horizon
de 5 à 10 ans on va avoir de plus en
plus d'autonomie accessibles dans les
voitures aujourd'hui les salariés de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux ont pu tester les
vélos électriques au pied de l'immeuble
Futura la société néovelec organisait
une journée d'animation pour découvrir
ce mode de transport en France 17
millions de Français font du vélo une
fois par semaine et 3 millions
quotidiennement alors pour développer
encore plus l'utilisation du vélo en
entreprise le gouvernement a lancé en
masse ce dernier des mesures pardon
comme l'obligation de créer des 2015 des
parkings à vélo dans les immeubles
disposant de place de stationnement auto
ou encore l'instauration d'une indemnité
kilométrique vélo 25 centimes par
kilomètre remboursé aux utilisateurs
nous vous avions déjà parlé du
développement d'entreprises de vélo
électrique qui vont dans ce sens pour
Thierry ordinez les entreprises et leurs
salariés sont une clientèle non
négligeable
à gauche pas mal de gens s'intéressent
aux vélos assistance électrique et me
contactent parce que ils ont envie
d'aller au vélo au travail à vélo pardon
ça peut être aussi des sportifs qui font
vraiment du VTT par exemple ou de du
vélo de route là le week-end et la
semaine ils veulent continuer à faire du
vélo mais ils veulent arriver frais
dispo au bureau et par en sueur tout le
monde n'a pas forcément une douche dans
son bureau et donc du coup le vélo
assistance électrique leur permet
d'aller au travail à vélo sans pour
autant transpirer je connaissais pas du
tout c'est intéressant c'est surprenant
pour moi je pense pas que ça
m'intéressera tout de suite je pense
plutôt à mes parents qui commencent à
avoir un peu de mal et je pense que là
ça peut être très intéressant par contre
après dans le dans l'idée de venir à
vélo au boulot pourquoi pas bizarre
tout doucement et alors qu'on va très
vite non c'est par contre c'est agréable
et les Yvelines sont évidemment un grand
terrain de jeu pour les cyclistes une
nouvelle société Miss d'ailleurs sur cet
engouement bike and test propose de
tester des vélos avant de les acheter en
ligne reportage réalisé avec Jonathan
Willmann
chaque année 3 millions de cycles sont
vendus dans l'Hexagone car le vélo est
une activité très prisé des Français
dans les Yvelines on compte plus d'une
centaine de clubs cyclistes des
kilomètres de pistes l'arrivée l'année
dernière du Vélodrome et d'une piste de
BMX donc renforcer l'attribut du
département pour les cyclistes fabrice
est lui-même un passionné après une
première expérience de vente pour une
marque de VTT français il a choisi de
lancer sa propre société un centre de
test pour vélo on se dit que il y avait
beaucoup de marques qui se vendaient sur
Internet toutes ces marques n'a pas la
possibilité de les voir on peut juste
les regarder sur internet regarder des
essais magazines des essais voilà de
sites internet mais concrètement on peut
pas voir le produit on peut pas
l'essayer donc voilà il y a un
réellement là-dedans c'est pour ça que
biken test est né les cyclistes peuvent
ainsi tester le matériel montant de 20 à
60 euros selon le modèle une somme qui
est remboursée si le test se conclut par
un achat contrairement aux autres
centres de tests bike and test ne vend
pas de vélo son activité se résume à du
conseil il guide les clients dans leur
choix et dans leur démarche d'achat en
ligne le prix sera le même pour lui
juste nous on apportera notre conseil et
on peut aussi réceptionner le vélo pour
lui réceptionner son matériel ici le
monter sur son vélo s'il a besoin on a
également un service atelier chez bike
interest pour réparer tout type de vélo
vélo de ville VTT vélo de route la
société propose également quelques
équipements et articles textiles des
accords avec les différentes marques lui
permettent de rentabiliser son activité
mais ici pas d'exclusivité une dizaine
de marques sont actuellement disponibles
une offre qui devrait doubler d'ici le
mois prochain
et zoom maintenant sur la formation en
alternance une session de recrutement
était organisée ce mercredi l'occasion
de découvrir ce mode de formation des
images de Patrick Jacques de bismud
d'une chambre une formation et un
premier pas dans le monde du travail
c'est ce que recherche ces jeunes
présents ce mercredi à la Cité des
Métiers et attrapes certains n'ont pas
encore le bac d'autres finissent un
cursus universitaires mais tous ont opté
pour l'alternance le temps de la
formation est ainsi partagé entre un
centre de formation et une entreprise
Jules l'état actuel du marché du travail
c'est bien d'avoir de l'expérience
puisque même en
offre d'emploi junior il demande 2 à 3
ans d'expérience ce qui est difficile
quand on sort de l'école donc là une
attente au moins un an d'expérience
concrète plus qu'un stage
c'est le plus grand employabilité et
l'un des principaux arguments des
centres de formation pour de nombreux
entreprises l'alternance est devenue un
moyen de recrutement efficace 50% des
jeunes restent dans l'entreprise parce
qu'ils ont fait des preuves et que
effectivement l'entreprise se sert de
cette première période pour juger qu'un
jeune est capable de rester ensuite en
poste dans les trois écoles yvelinoise
de la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
80% des diplômés trouvent un poste en
CDI dans un délai de six mois 1800
jeunes ils sont formés chaque année ces
derniers temps l'apprentissage s'est
ouvert à toutes les filières et à tous
les niveaux d'études en contrat
d'apprentissage pour les moins de 26 ans
ou de professionnels les apprentis
deviennent de véritables salariés on
peut mettre presque immédiatement nos
acquis en place en pratique et que tout
en continuant à aller à l'école on peut
gagner de l'argent
l'entreprise leur verse effectivement un
salaire mais elle y trouve également un
avantage financier le contrat
d'apprentissage par exemple est exonéré
des charges patronales c'est aussi le
moyen de trouver les bons candidats un
certain nombre d'entreprises qui ont un
certain volume aussi réalisent en la
voie de l'alternance des formations
dédiées c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont 10 15 20
apprentis à recruter et il y a 20 postes
en CDD CDI on organise avec eux on
identifie leurs besoins nos équipes
pédagogiques travaillent sur un
programme de formation et on monte une
formation sur 6 mois un an deux ans
aujourd'hui au-delà des jeunes de
nombreux demandeurs d'emploi se tournent
vers des contrats de
professionnalisation
cet entretien est consacré au réseau
d'entreprises business net nous recevons
Marie-Anne erra bonsoir alors j'indiquer
au début de cette émission c'est un
réseau pas comme les autres pourquoi
alors parce que vraiment ce qui est très
important c'est la convivialité et
l'efficacité professionnelle et en fait
les deux mélangés ça crée vraiment en
fait des liens très forts d'affaires et
je dis bien d'affaires parce que ça
réseau professionnel et en même temps
bien les personnes en fait arrivent à se
connaître aussi sur un plan personnel
donc il peut y avoir aussi des amitiés
qui se créent et en fait c'est aussi un
réseau pas comme les autres parce que en
fait il y a des tables ce qu'on appelle
des tables des entrepreneurs ce sont des
tables qui sont ouvertes à tout le monde
et les personnes peuvent venir quand
elles veulent entre une plage horaire
donc ça c'est extraordinaire finalement
à tous gratuits les gens viennent selon
leur disponibilités il y a pas
d'engagement à tenir alors nous avons
rencontré un autre membre du réseau
Sophie Caty elle est consultante en
management le réseau lui a permis par
exemple de trouver des clients mais
au-delà elle apprécie justement cette
ouverture d'état d'esprit et ce côté
ouvert à tous c'est gratuit on l'écoute
on vient y trouver ce qu'on y apporte et
c'est très clair dès le départ dans
d'autres réseaux il faut payer pour
rentrer chez nommerai pas d'autres sont
plus fermés je me souviens d'avoir
essayé en 2009 d'intégrer un réseau
j'étais à l'époque on ne partage
salarial on dit non mais madame vous
êtes pas vous êtes pas entrepreneur on
veut pas de vous bon ok en exclu
business net on peut trouver ça arrive
de temps en temps qui est quelqu'un qui
cherche du boulot qui vient nous voir et
qui propose son offre on a des gens de
grandes entreprises aussi qui viennent
passer un déjeuner comme ça une fois de
temps en temps
alors le réseau existe depuis 17 ans
donc il n'est pas nouveau mais au départ
il y avait finalement que des tables
d'entrepreneurs en introduction ces
réunions hebdomadaires depuis un an le
réseau c'est largement étoffé après de
l'ampleur alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
amené alors on s'est réuni et en fait il
y a aussi bien des ateliers des
conférences et puis donc là nous lançons
notre première grande soirée expertise
et talent des adhérents de business net
alors ce sera le 13 juin à la Maison de
l'Entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines donc c'est
ouvert à tous mais ce sont des adhérents
qui animent finalement les conférenciers
les animateurs des ateliers où ils sont
justement des adhérents parce que c'est
ça vraiment l'important c'est de mettre
en avant le savoir-faire et l'expertise
que les personnes ont au sein de
business net il y en a beaucoup
l'adhésion c'est aussi quelque chose que
vous avez apporté oui alors l'adhésion
est vraiment pas très cher c'est 35
euros pour l'année et grâce à l'adhésion
alors non seulement on peut avoir des
réductions sur les événements qu'on
organise mais en même temps là il y a un
site internet qui est en train de se
monter de se créer et justement les
adhérents pourront avoir une fiche de
présentation et un lien s'il le souhaite
direct sur leur site
alors c'est donc parmi les adhérents qui
animeront par exemple cette soirée on
compte ils vont encore vésiers et il
gère un cabinet d'avocat il fait partie
de plusieurs réseaux d'entrepreneurs
c'est un moyen pour lui de faire du
business c'est le but et ce qu'il
apprécie ici dans son dans ce réseau
c'est aussi ce côté convivial et aussi
le partage d'expérience je vous propose
d'écouter son intervention aujourd'hui
le chef d'entreprise alors que je suis
et par ma fonction d'avocats que je
conseille également
à cette particularité d'être plus
souvent seul
et le fait de se retrouver dans des
lieux comme celui-là avec l'idée de
faire du business parce qu'il faut pas
s'en cacher on est là pour pour
rencontrer des futurs clients et aussi
des futurs fournisseurs mais le faire
dans un cas de convivial qui permet
surtout et c'est ce que je vois de
sortir d'un isolement de pouvoir avoir
un partage d'expérience de pouvoir faire
part de ces difficultés parce qu'on a ça
aussi des chefs d'entreprise qui
connaissent des passages à vide on en a
tous et qui peuvent en parler
alors combien de sympathisants à peu
près aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui il y
a peu près 700 sympathisants et une
soixantaine d'adhérents et donc du coup
c'est aussi l'occasion peut-être
aujourd'hui tout à fait de faire une
campagne de faire un appel et on
rappelle donc du coup cette soirée du 13
juin voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être venu d'être venu sur notre
plateau merci on passe tout de suite
c'est l'une des mesures phares de la
réforme territoriale annoncée par
François Hollande il y a quelques jours
réalisés des économies d'échelle et
réduire les dotations de l'État aux
collectivité locale de 10 milliards
d'euros d'ici 2007 dans les Yvelines à
chaque communauté de réagir au mieux
tour d'horizon au Chesnay à Bois-d'Arcy
et à Magny-les-Hameaux un dossier
réalisé par la rédaction
c'est fait dans la plupart des villes le
budget a été voté au Conseil municipal
et dans toutes les communes les mers
font face à une baisse importante des
dotations de l'État - 1 milliard et demi
cette année pour l'ensemble des
collectivités au Chesnay le maire a
alors décidé d'augmenter les impôts
locaux de 2,5% soit environ 15 euros de
plus par foyer je pense que de toute
façon il y a beaucoup de choses qui
augmentent bon maintenant réduire les
dépenses oui de toute façon il faut les
réduire cela dit je fais confiance à la
gestion de Monsieur le Maire ici pour
pour serrer les choses au mieux je ne
suis pas d'accord j'aimerais mieux que
on diminue
qu'on nous augmente pas nos impôts
locaux et évidemment je pense qu'on
pourrait réduire les dépenses au niveau
des espaces verts c'est bien on a des
beaux jardins des belles fleurs mais
peut-être que là il y a un petit peu
d'abus je pense que si c'est vraiment
important pour l'équilibre du budget de
la vie pourquoi pas au Chesnay le maire
affirme que le déficit du budget 2014 et
d'un millions d'euros par rapport à 2013
cette augmentation des impôts qui
rapporterait 350 000 euros à la commune
lui permettrait alors d'aider à
équilibrer le budget de fonctionnement
il faut savoir pardon que une commune
comme Le Chesnay quand on augmente d'1%
la totalité de nos impôts
et bien nous avons
126000 euros de recettes 126000 euros ce
qui est pas énorme sachant que un agent
coûte à peu près 35000 euros donc ça
veut dire que si on veut embaucher trois
agents temps plein sur l'année il ne
faut 1% d'impôts donc là on avait besoin
de 2% pour maintenir les investissements
maintenant les activités même si on
diminue tout donc voilà la première
raison de l'augmentation de la fiscalité
des économies sont également prévues
dans d'autres domaines on avait prévu
d'améliorer certains services en
augmentant quelques personnel pas
d'augmentation
nous avons pris le choix aussi de
diminuer un certain nombre d'éléments
qu'ils soient je dirais événementiel
qu'il soit autre donc on on rate un
petit peu sur l'ensemble sur les
subventions sur le tout et donc
obligatoirement c'est l'effet un petit
peu du domino quand l'État diminue bah
tout le monde doit diminuer et on le
ressent aussi là gérer le budget d'une
commune un vrai travail d'équilibre
entre les dépenses et les recettes au
niveau des recettes deux sources
principales les impôts locaux et les
financements de l'État parmi les impôts
locaux on compte la taxe d'habitation
payée par tous les habitants la taxe
foncière payée par les propriétaires de
biens immobiliers ces impôts sont
calculés en fonction de la valeur
estimée du loyer des habitations et d'un
taux défini par la commune avec la Val
de l'État
deuxième source principale des recettes
les financements de l'État depuis la
décentralisation votée en 1982 ce sont
les communes qui gèrent les crèches ou
les constructions des écoles primaires
et maternelles par exemple des projets
financés par l'État
à noter que comme les loyers varient
selon les communes les recettes
provenant des taxes d'habitation et des
taxes foncières peuvent être très
inégales d'une communion à l'autre pour
favoriser l'égalité l'état donne donc
plus aux communes les moins riches via
en fondational de péréquation
intercommunale et communale un fond
auquel participent une grande majorité
des communes des Yvelines plutôt
favorisées dans l'ensemble du coup une
partie de leurs ressources sont
prélevées pour être reversés aux
communes les moins riches
les dépenses elles peuvent être de 3
types il y a d'abord les dépenses de
fonctionnement comme les salaires des
employés municipaux par exemple ensuite
les dépenses d'équipement comme la
construction d'une école enfin le
remboursement des emprunts que la
commune a pu faire auparavant
à Bois-d'Arcy commune qui a basculé à
droite le nouveau maire Philippe
Benassaya s'était engagé durant sa
campagne à ne pas augmenter les impôts
des habitants en 2014 et 2015 lui fait
donc le choix d'économiser sur le train
de vie de la commune le train de vie
c'est la communication c'est les
événements l'événementiel comme on dit
on touchera pas au social bien
évidemment parce que là ce sont des
priorités mais on va essayer de réduire
train de vie lorsqu'on a plus d'argent
dans un dans un ménage on continue pas à
sortir en restaurant au cinéma etc c'est
à peu près la même chose à noter qu'en
plus de la baisse des dotations de
l'État le maire doit compenser également
les 475 000 euros que la communauté
d'agglomération de Versailles Grand Parc
ne lui versera pas cette année
direction manileamo ici d'après le maire
socialiste le budget se porte plutôt
bien dans l'ensemble ça n'empêche que on
reste aujourd'hui toujours inquiet sur
ces annonces qui sont faites au fur et à
mesure sur les diminutions de moyens
vers les collectivités et à côté donc
l'évolution des services qui sont
demandés par les habitants je prends
l'exemple de la restauration scolaire
aujourd'hui on a quasiment 90% des 1000
élèves de la commune qui mange le midi
dans les écoles
c'est une forte évolution et qui a
forcément un coup sur le budget de la
commune puisqu'il y a une participation
de la part communale dans dans cet
ensemble
Bertrand Houillon avait estimé la baisse
de dotation globale de fonctionnement à
5% elle est finalement de 9%. du coup
des économies sont tout de même à
prévoir
on les fait au jour le jour sur les
achats dans les services de
de faire attention sur le renouvellement
de matériel de faire attention sur
l'utilisation de fournitures de faire
attention sur
le chauffage par exemple de l'ensemble
des bâtiments de renégocier aussi
l'ensemble des des
contrats qu'on peut avoir des contrats
d'assurance par exemple même si c'est à
chaque fois toujours très difficile
parce qu'on sait chacun qui a son budget
personnel voit bien que la vie augmente
l'année prochaine les dotations de
l'État seraient encore réduite de 3
milliards puis encore rabotés de 3
milliards en 2016 et 2017 soit un total
proche de 10 milliards d'euros d'ici la
fin du quinquennat
et on finit avec l'agenda on vous en
parlait dans le filet écho l'alternance
attire de nombreuses personnes jeunes au
moins jeunes alors une journée
d'information aura lieu à la Cité des
Métiers mardi prochain de 14h à 17h des
accueillants individuels par des centres
de formation pour s'y connaître les
secteurs concernés et les modalités
pratiques et puis je vous le rappelle
vendredi prochain de 18h30 à 21h30 à la
Maison de l'Entreprise de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la soirée
expertise et talent de business net
c'est la fin de ce filet co merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez-vous jeudi
prochain très bonne soirée